[Musique]
on va poser une dernière question à ce
qu'à votre avis thierry va revenir ou
pas et je vais vous dire ce que vous
pensez que c'est un coup de tête qu'est
ce qu'il va revenir ou pas non non non
pas pas mûrement réfléchie non non moi
je pense pas que soient durement
réfléchit non et non max et il avait
l'air assez décidé je l adore tiens il
ya aussi des gens qui ont dit que c'est
à cause d'eux maxime gainey anna des
gens lucides et on dit alors je vais
vous lire le sms de thierry qui m'a
envoyé ce matin cyril ce que j'ai envoyé
un petit sms voilà je vais me voilà
appelle moi quand tu te sentiras je
t'embrasse syrie cyril tout va bien je
n'ai pas de problème de santé parce
qu'on avait j'ai pris la décision de
partir il ya quelques semaines déjà
j'ai saisi l'opportunité du mercato des
chroniqueurs pour le faire tu n'y est
évidemment pour rien je sais que tu as
été surpris je n'en avais parlé à
personne
j'ai passé grâce à toi c'est ton
merveilleux dans tpm paix tu m'a permis
de vivre des moments incroyables
parmi les plus incroyables de ma vie je
ne te remercierai jamais assez pour ça
je pense en revanche qu'il nous faut
faire et qu'il ne faut pas faire le
match de trop
sept ans c'est bien et surtout l'arrivée
de maxime n'y est pour rien je vais
d'ailleurs envoyé un sms pour lui dire
absolument envoyer un sms est étudié
pour rien et ma décision était prise
bien avant
et puis on sentait on s'entendait mais
tellement bien regardez par exemple hier
à l école décédé trop non plus avait
déjeuné ensemble
c'est un très bon chroniqueur et
journaliste tout comme agathe et
géraldine je ne parle évidemment pas
pour autre chose
je pars juste je continuerai à vous
regarder à rire avec vous derrière mon
écran et vous allez continuer à
cartonner car vous êtes unique et
surtout je continuerai à défendre bec et
ongles la famille tpm pct top bonne
route
bis fidèles thierry moreau qui voulant
rapidement
[Musique]
en tout cas
ça c'est le hérie moreau sera toujours
le bienvenu autour de la table de tpm
paix et je n'embrasse très très fort mon
titi et ce sera toujours quelqu'un de ma
famille et je serai toujours là si d'un
souci et même si l'on n'a pas d'ailleurs
voilà comme ça je vous le dire car ils
vous envoyer en tirant et un texte aussi
juste pendant la pub il m'a dit vraiment
désolé de te plombé sa chronique deux
soirs de suite mais tu es super tu
devrait récupérer ma pige pour toi voilà
il est déjà plus de rôle